alerte aux inondations dans la somme en
dépit des travaux réalisés depuis la
crue de l'an dernier les digues et les
canaux ne suffisent plus à contenir la
montée des eaux
à toulouse des chiraquiens de l'union en
mouvement en accueilli fraîchement
françois bayrou qui n'était pas invité
le président de l'idf a expliqué qu'un
parti unique de la droite serait une
faute
le salon de l'agriculture a ouvert ses
portes pour neuf jours à paris
aujourd'hui c'était l'arrivée du public
avant les visites incontournables des
hommes politiques
les victoires de la musique c'est sur
france 2 et c'est dans quinze jours
invité de ce journal laurent voulzy dont
l'album a été sélectionné pour cette
compétition
madame monsieur bonsoir dans la somme la
situation est jugée extrêmement
préoccupante même si les débordements
reste localisée la préfecture a réactivé
sa cellule d'alert mise en place l'an
dernier la somme redoutent de connaître
le même scénario les nappes phréatiques
sont tous plus haut et les grandes
marées prévues dans le courant de la
semaine prochaine pourrait accentuer le
gonflement du fleuve sur place mathias
hillion et maya l'uci
de l'outil le plus dérisoires au plus
efficace ici tout est bon pour endiguer
la montée des eaux plus 5 cm la nuit
dernière à epagny tous les habitants
sont mobilisés
tous sauf un on a effectué une digue
pendant les travaux qui est efficace
quoi voilà voilà donc celle ci retient
bien l'eau par contre de l'autre côté
propriétaire récalcitrant n'a pas voulu
commenter chez lui pour travailler qui
nous a refusé l'accès pour faire la
digue au pad digues l'eau déborde ça
remonte dans le village
la première victime des inondations
c'est elle yvette billiers pour protéger
sa maison de l'eau la direction
départementale de l'équipement lui a
fourni des sacs de sable déjà sinistré
l'année dernière elle aussi pointe du
doigt son voisin c'est le propriétaire à
tout ça on peut même pas faire les
fossés on peut rien faire veut pas faire
les digues alors comme ça on a de l'eau
et puis c'est tout le temps répété j'ai
eu 50 cm dans la maison ont fini les
travaux seulement là dans huit jours ça
va être fini et puis l'ol revient le
riverain mise en cause explique son
refus par un contentieux avec le maire
pour lui même avec des digues la somme
continuera de déborder tant qu'elle ne
sera pas draguer bref ses détracteurs
aurait trouvé en lui un parfait bouc
émissaire ce sont des sceaux s imagine
peut-être que je fais exprès les noyer
le ridicule a toujours été noyé par
exemple les maps plus grands enfants se
séparer
ces digues vont elles résister aux forts
coefficients de marée prévus pour
mercredi
difficile pour l'instant de le dire les
habitants des pagnes en tout cas volts y
croire depuis l'an dernier où une
centaine de communes avait été inondé de
nombreux travaux ont été effectués on
vient de le voir construction de digues
élargissement de kano mais le dispositif
reste insuffisant aurélia guima marianne
masse et patrick bullestorm combien de
temps ces digues résisteront-elles avec
92 mètre cube d'eau déversées chaque
seconde
la somme ne laisse aucun répit depuis
les débordements du printemps dernier le
flat va pourtant reçu toutes les
attentions des berges réhaussé sur
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres des
ponts démoli pour être mieux reconstruit
un lit nettoyer
autant de travaux pour que c'est cool tu
enfin ces millions de mètres cubes d'eau
seulement voilà cette saison encore les
précipitations dépassent largement la
moyenne et les nappes phréatiques encore
gorgés des pluies de l'an passé saturent
les eaux de pluie des hypers de
l'automne et de l'hiver s'infiltre
facilement au travers des fissures de la
craie finissent par s'accumuler
c'est la baignoire avec un robin à 12
heures et une évacuation qui est
insuffisant d'autant que vous ne fermez
pas trop pinel à la baignoire se remplir
alors montera en flèche ce qui se passe
au niveau du bassin de la somme finale
un tel débit a provoqué l'année dernière
de graves inondations
preuve de l'efficacité des travaux on ne
recense pour l'instant que quelques
habitations inondées
mais dans quelques jours ce seront les
grandes marées il faudra alors fermé les
écluses au risque de voir leur remontée
et avec elle de bien mauvais souvenirs
en grande bretagne de véritables
tempêtes de neige ont balayé le pays de
l'ecosse à l'irlande
deux personnes ont trouvé la mort près
de 1600 foyers sont privés d'électricité
et les autorités britanniques demandent
d'éviter les déplacements
gilles marinais neige vent verglas
déroute transformer en piège pour les
automobilistes du nord de l'angleterre
deux personnes sont mortes malgré les
appels à la prudence lancés par les
services météorologiques en écosse il a
fallu secourir 16 personnes bloquées
dans leur véhicule par des congères
circulation interrompue également sur
plusieurs autoroutes et voies ferrées
plus au sud
c'est un vent violent qui a causé de
nombreuses chutes d'arbres et renversé
des véhicules bourrasques hier sur
l'aéroport de leeds bradford les
passagers de l'avion se rappelleront
longtemps de ce décollage et l'on
prévoit encore du vent des tempêtes et
de la neige pour les prochaines 24
heures la neige qui tombe aussi en
abondance sur le nord de l'europe
la suède et sa capitale stockholm vivent
au ralenti en norvège
il faut évacuer des trains ce sont des
chenillettes qui ramèneront les
passagers dans des abris chauffés où ils
pourront passer la nuit sur les côtes du
pays
c'est le vent qui rend périlleuse la
traversée des ponts la police en
interdit l'accès dans le nord de
l'europe pour le printemps il faudra
encore attendre un peu en france
heureusement la météo est plus clémente
sur la route des vacances la circulation
est particulièrement dense week-end
n'est pas de véritables difficultés
n'oubliez pas pour autant les consignes
de sécurité au volant la journée du
dimanche reste elle aussi chargé à
toulouse les chiraquiens de l'union en
mouvement ont réservé un accueil plutôt
le à françois bayrou il est vrai que le
président de l'udf et candidat à
l'élection présidentielle a plaidé pour
le respect des différences et s'est
prononcé contre la constitution d'un
parti unique de la droite qui serait
selon lui une faute
de son côté jacques chirac a adressé un
message pour saluer cette journée
d'engagement et de rassemblement sur
place filet boisserie
et daniel et non le temps d'une
éclaircie philippe douste-blazy est allé
accueillir celui qu'on n'attendait pas
et qui est venu au nom du principe que
quand on a des choses à se dire je l' ai
dit les yeux dans les yeux et face à
face en tout cas ici sur la terre de
rugby quel sud ouest patrick stefanini
directeur adjoint de la campagne de
jacques chirac et philippe douste blazy
gère l'arrivée contre mauvaise fortune
bon coeur
nous ne souhaitons pas qu'il y ait au
contraire des disputes dans l'opposition
nous souhaitons qu'il y ait une victoire
de l'opposition au second tour face à
monsieur gestion et tout est fait pour
organiser un accueil chaleureux à défaut
d'être toujours sincère à celui qui
vient pourtant dénoncé l'hégémonisme
d'un parti unique
réunis derrière un seul homme si nous
pensons tous la même chose c'est que
nous ne pensons plus rien alors il y à
des lieux
au premier sifflet alain juppé
intervient pour demander le respect
françois bayrou rajoute alors une bonne
dose de culot
je ne sais pas qui gagnera
on a vu en 1995 chirac chirac
on a vu en 1995 comment les pronostics
pouvait se renverser à cela alain juppé
préfère la politique de la main tendue à
celui qui se dit aussi prêt à soutenir
jacques chirac au second tour un jacques
chirac qui n'est pas venue mais qui a
fait lire un message par le maire
démocratie libérale de marseille
choyé mobilisés et disponible pour
servir l'espoir qui se lève pour la
france voilà les chers amis ce que
jacques chirac va demander de vous lire
un discours beaucoup plus compréhensible
pour une grande partie de la salle
et pendant ce temps à stockholm ou
l'autre candidat lionel jospin a assisté
au sommet des modernisateurs qui
regroupe les onze chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de la gauche européenne
le premier ministre français a été
accueilli chaleureusement par ses
confrères ils ont apporté leur soutien
j'avais imbert et à la location
si je mets le jospin confectionne un
album souvenir avec les photos de sa
campagne présidentielle
alors celles ci risquent d'y figurer en
bonne place le premier ministre candidat
au milieu de quelques têtes d'affiché
internationales pour lui pas de doute la
réunion de stockholm aura au moins sept
vertus hier les progressistes comme ils
se baptisent même sont arrivés en suède
sous une tempête de neige
dennis blair gerhard schröder mais aussi
le président brésilien le numéro un
sud-africain d'autres encore ils sont
douze au total dans ce club dont les
réunions se veulent moins protocolaire
qu'un traditionnel sommet on y évoque
pourtant les mêmes sujets le proche
orient avec un appel lancé à sharon et
arafat mais on s'y échangent aussi
paraît il des conseils des petits trucs
ainsi lorsqu'un membre du club est
candidat à une présidentielle d'autres
membres déjà président
sont sollicités jospin n'a pas besoin
des conseils la gagner beaucoup des
élections il connaît bien la beauté
française
en réalité les trois présidents qui se
sont exprimés et quelques autres
premiers ministres
ils m'ont donné de très bons conseils de
très bons conseils et je m'efforcerai
bien sûr de les suivre
une chose est sûre la photo de famille
de stockholm est censée tomber au
meilleur moment pour les jo ce pas avant
le congrès socialiste de demain qui doit
l'introniser auprès des militants le
tempo de cette entrée en campagne du
candidat jospin a décidément été très
étudié jacques chirac et lionel jospin
qui sont aujourd'hui à égalité au 2e
tour selon un sondage réalisé par l'ifop
pour le journal du dimanche de demain au
premier tour jacques chirac devant ce
lunel je parle d'un point avec 25% des
intentions de vote
jean pierre chevènement arrive en
troisième position avec 10% devant
arlette laguiller 8% jean marie le pen
7% et noël mamère 6%
bruno mégret qui dans ce sondage n'est
crédité que de 1% des intentions de vote
tiens convention nationale aujourd'hui
et demain à nice bruno mégret affirme
qu'il obtiendra les 500 signatures
nécessaires à sa candidature
reportage auprès des cadres du mouvement
et ambiance avec michael marmot et
patrick d'esprit abonnés maigret seul
candidat à la présidence oui miss et à
celle de son parti le mnr en attendant
mieux
peut-être ce qui est important c'est les
élections pour la france et là je me
présente aussi j'aurai mes signatures
pour remettre de l'ordre en france
remettre de l'ordre la grande affaire du
parti mégrétistes et à nice tout le
monde s'y met y compris les jeunes du
mnj qui ne mâchent pas leurs mots 1er
mai gré et à travers lui le mnr et le
mnj sont les seuls mouvements défendre
réellement l'identité française et
européenne que ce soit d'un point de vue
ethnique ou culturelle ici les affiches
et les mesures proposées sont radicales
le mnr prépare sa campagne
présidentielle alors qu'il n'a toujours
pas les 500 signatures
le parti issu de la scission du front
national s'affirme comme le représentant
d'une droite extrême avec ses modèles
comme ça s'est fait en italie comme ça
s'est fait en autriche
il n'y a pas de raison que ça se passe
ailleurs en europe et que ça ne se passe
pas demain en france nos idées on vend
pour mais pour l'instant les vents
semblent plutôt contraire adorent les
militants mégrétistes rassembleur
énergie veulent y croire
et chacun y va de son petit conseil
après le futuroscope près de poitiers
voici le naturoscope un autre parc
construit cette fois sur le thème de la
nature d'où son nom
il pourrait voir le jour en 2003 dans le
nord du département de la vienne mais il
suscite déjà de nombreuses critiques
aujourd'hui plus d'un millier de
militants écologistes s'étaient
rassemblés pour dénoncer ce qu'ils
considèrent comme une opération purement
commerciales avec parmi eux noël mamère
que françois privat et alain darrigrand
rencontré noël mamère en campagne à
poitiers au côté des associations qui
s'opposent aux natura scop
la nouvelle idée de rené monory un
futuroscope de la nature qui serait
principalement financé par les
collectivités locales à hauteur de 50
millions d'euros
est ce que la bonne méthode c'est de
faire un futuroscope qui est en train de
perdre de l'argent de le compléter après
par un natura'zik up qui va essayer de
qui va faire une sorte de l'una parc de
la nature au contraire de se lancer dans
une agriculture qui respecte le
consommateur l'alimentation et
l'environnement
nous sommes dans la forêt de ses vols
dans le nord de la vienne c'est ici sur
95 ha qu'un parc principalement orientée
autour de la nature pourrait voir le
jour en 2003 un petit frère du
futuroscope qui selon rené monory
pourrait attirer 500 mille visiteurs par
an et créer 200 emplois
ce sera beaucoup autour de nature que ce
sera dans une partie peut habiter avec
beaucoup de bois beaucoup d'eau et sera
sur le site les opposants manifestent
régulièrement alors que les travaux de
défrichement ont déjà commencé on veut
réconcilier avec la nature et pour cela
on coupe vingt ou trente ou quarante
hectares de ladite nature et voilà à
quoi donc déjà c'est un non sens
en novembre dernier une décision du
tribunal administratif de poitiers a
validé la délibération du conseil
général de la vienne qui donné naissance
au naturisme c'est dans ce climat
électoral aussi que le ministre de
l'économie et des finances avant son
projet de prélèvement des impôts à la
source mais pour éviter de faire payer
deux fois l'impôt l'année du passage des
prélèvements prévisionnel à l'impôt à la
source
laurent fabius on envisage de faire
cadeau d'une année d'impôt soit 50
milliards d'euros une aubaine pour les
contribuables du moins en apparence
céline crespy
elle est bleue en euros et vous l'avez
peut-être déjà reçu dans votre boîte aux
lettres sur votre feuille d'impôts 2002
vous allez déclarer vos revenus de l'an
dernier ainsi les impôts que vous
verserez ne correspondent pas à ce que
vous gagnez actuellement un décalage qui
pourrait disparaître si le ministère des
finances mettait en place le prélèvement
à la source ou l'impôt est directement
retirer de votre salaire et là surprise
une année entière forêt bien passer à la
trappe
si jamais on était en place ce système
pour 2003
ça veut dire qu'en 2003 sur les salaires
que je perçois les impôts serait
automatiquement prélevée par
l'entreprise dans laquelle je travaille
en 2002 dans le système actuel j'ai payé
mes impôts sur le revenu 2001
conclusion dans cette transition devrait
pas d'impôts sur les revenus que
j'aurais touché en 2002 mais ne rêvons
pas il faudra bien payer des impôts
prélevés l'impôt à la source c'est déjà
ce que font tous les autres pays de
l'union européenne et ce système a
l'avantagé pour le contribuable de
rendre plus claires son pouvoir d'achat
et de le faire bénéficier plus vite les
baisses d'impôts les 85 mille salariés
de la direction générale des impôts
redoute eu des réductions d'effectifs
près de 600 personnes ont participé
aujourd'hui en avignon à une marche
silencieuse en hommage à marie andrée
fresquet cette vieille dame sauvagement
violée et tuée en janvier dernier la
personnalité de cette grand mère
particulièrement dynamique et généreuse
avait fait d'elle une figure de la vie
le président jacques chirac vient de
faire part de son inquiétude sur la
situation au proche orient dans un
entretien téléphonique avec son
homologue américain le président george
bush jacques chirac a déclaré que le
conflit est en train de changer de
nature et oblige à révèle une autre
approche indique le porte-parole de
l'elysée il a plaidé pour une
application plus grand des américains
dans la reprise d'un processus politique
à madagascar les partisans de marc
ravalomanana qui s'était auto proclamé
hier président de la république ont
manifesté aujourd'hui contre l'état
d'urgence décrété par le président
sortant didier ratsiraka au pouvoir
depuis près de 15 ans marc ravalomanane
estimé avoir été élu président dès le
premier tour en décembre dernier contre
l'actuel titulaire qui lui avait
organisé un deuxième tour prévu pour
dimanche prochain sur place eric monier
et bruno girodon ils sont là distille
pour protéger marc ravalomanane leur
nouveau président ou celui qu'il
considère comme tel depuis son
autoproclamation hier voilà des semaines
qu'il tombe sur les hauteurs
d'antananarive devant son domicile
jusqu'ici ils étaient des centaines
depuis l'instauration de l'état
d'urgence hier ils sont désormais des
milliers près a pu pour éviter
l'arrestation toujours possible de leur
leader
car ils en sont convaincus le président
sortant didier ratsiraka au pouvoir
pendant plus de 25 ans n'abandonnera pas
la partie aussi facilement 7 6 go ce
messie cosneau fut de président que
ratsiraka
ça fait quand même malheureux c'est pas
de la dynastie c'est pas la monarchie
on pressent la république et pourtant ça
ne fait pas de la république en presse à
l'alternance et pourtant ya pas de date
d rose cette nuit la communauté
internationale à condamner leurs actions
parlant de coup de force
de quoi irriter les militants ici qui
oppose à la stricte légalité la
légitimité populaire
on comprend bien que la france les états
unis défendent la légalité mais il faut
voir la réalité à madagascar d'ici là
misère est ce que vous pensez
si la mise et à madagascar ont laissé de
transporter s'utiliser en france est ce
que vous allez dire hancock la légalité
cécile fo défend toujours la légalité
dans les rues de la capitale
les bâtiments stratégiques sont protégés
par l'armée
son nervosité et si la majorité des
magasins restent fermés aucune tension
n'est perceptible même sur la route qui
mène à la résidence présidentielle
chacun vaque à ses occupations seuls
quelques militaires interdisent
fermement aux journalistes l'accès qui
conduit topal madagascar deux présidents
et bientôt deux gouvernements
marc ravalomanana serait en train de
former le sien avant d'en annoncer la
composition en début de semaine ce qui
devrait encore ajouter à la confusion
politique qui règne ici au large des
côtes siciliennes un vieux cargo avec à
son bord près de 400 migrants
clandestins a été pris en charge par les
autorités italiennes ces clandestins
venus du sri lanka ont passé six
semaines en mer à bord de ce bateau dans
des conditions où l'imaginé absolument
effroyable
le capitaine et les membres d'équipage
du bateau ont été arrêtées en angola le
chef de l'unita jonas savimbi ya été tué
c'est le principal chef rebelle dans la
guerre civile qui déchire l'angola
depuis l'indépendance en 75
il a trouvé la mort lors d'affrontements
avec l'armée dans le centre du pays sa
disparition relance les espoirs de paix
dans un pays ravagé depuis 26 ans par la
guerre
aux etats unis la maison blanche est
poursuivi en justice après le scandale
de la faillite du géant énergétique
enron selon la cour des comptes
américaine les liens entre la maison
blanche et les dirigeants du secteur
pétrole énergies sont obscures le vice
président dick cheney le premier visé
par ces critiques
les entreprises pétrolières américaines
ont largement participé au financement
de la campagne présidentielle sur place
pascal golomer et tristan le bras c'est
l'appartement de ken lay l'ancien patron
des neurones que nous montre coni
castilho il habite
comme tous les autres dirigeants du
groupe dont le quartier le plus huppé de
houston les dirigeants que kony respecté
jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient licenciés
brutalement et perdre ses économies
placées en actions enron qui ne valent
plus rien aujourd'hui si nous ont menti
ils savaient que la société allait
sombrer
ils ont gagné des millions de dollars en
se débarrassant de leurs actions avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard creignou en ago
tout perdu on a tous peur c'est tour
ultra moderne donnait pourtant au coeur
de la ville l'image une réussite
exemplaire apparence bien trompeuse car
les dirigeants truqué les comptes et
dissimulé des dettes gigantesques ils
ont vendu leurs actions avant le
naufrage
la plus grande faillite de l'histoire
des états unis michael affiché 20 ans de
maison
cadre supérieur il a dû abandonner son
bureau en 30 minutes
depuis il se bat avec des centaines
d'autres ex salariés pour tenter de
récupérer devant la justice tout ce
qu'ils ont perdu
nous réclamons nos indemnités de
licenciement nos vacances qui n'ont pas
été payés les dépenses qui n'ont jamais
été remboursés
et puis surtout nous voulons être
dédommagés pour tout ce que nous avons
perdu en misant sur l'action et non sur
ses gadgets d'une autre époque et
neurones vantait ses valeurs intégrité
restait le message apparaît aujourd'hui
à michael inconnu et à beaucoup d'autres
gagnent hypocrite cette affaire enron
passionne tant l'amérique c'est bien sûr
parce qu'il s'agit d'un gigantesque
scandale mais aussi parce que des
millions d'américains redoutent d'être
un jour victime du même système et de
perdre en quelques jours leur travail et
l'argent de leur retraite
le salon de l'agriculture a ouvert ce
matin ses portes au public
cette année plus encore que les autres
il sera le rendez vous incontournable
d'une part bonne partie de la classe
politique le président candidat jacques
chirac inaugurera officiellement le
salon demain dimanche à 8h30
lionel jospin s'y rendra lundi claudine
gilbert et marie cazaux nous donne les
grandes tendances de ce salon 2002
merci de la bière
ça c'est la vraie vient de nous de nos
campagnes à la vraie viande de nos
anciens des vaches strictement herbivore
au salon de l'agriculture on peut
vérifier soi même le contenu de leur
mangeoire pour s'en convaincre de la
pulpe de betteraves ont fait avec de
l'eau et puis un concentré de protéines
soja colza tournesol pour végétal
naturellement depuis la crise de la
vache folle la filière bovine ne ménage
pas ses efforts
ici les visiteurs sont cordialement
invités à retrouver le goût de la viande
l'avion volait des tams est rebouché et
a pas de mystère nous ont éclairés
consommateurs à dire d'où la bt le bien
où elle est née tout ça
la dégustation se veut studieuse chacun
doit exprimer ses sensations dans un
questionnaire
mais il n'est pas interdit de se régaler
se donne j'aime pas la viande rouge pour
ça que je suis venu
et je vois que c'est vraiment je crois
que ça va je vais relever les noms et je
crois que quand j'irai chez mon boucher
je vais lui demander ça les âmes
sensibles
elle préfère oublier que ces vaches ccvo
s'y attendait 100 pour le citadins en
mal de verdure finiront inexorablement
dans leur assiette
tout est assez violent de montrer les
quartiers de viande à côté de mes vaches
sur pied je pensais mise en scène fait
un peu pâle urtois couper l'appétit aux
plus gourmands des visiteurs
quant aux animaux leur besoin de
consolation est impossible à rassasier
pour être parfaitement informés sur les
conditions d'élevage quoi de mieux que
l'achat direct à la ferme
c'est une formule qui se développe pour
faire face à la crise de la viande
bovine de nombreux agriculteurs vendent
directement aux consommateurs
laurence de chef et vincent ferreira ont
rencontré des éleveurs normands qui
écoule de la sorte toute leur production
quand elle ne s'occupe pas de ses vaches
isabelle s'occupe de ses clients
les particuliers qui en pleine crise de
la vache folle ne font plus confiance
aux revendeurs cette science préfère ne
pas manger de viande quand elle ne peut
être livrés là au moins je sais d'où
vient la viande dans un hypermarché
auchan est un boucher on peut toujours
me raconter des histoires après
l'abattage de leurs vaches il a bel et
jérôme ou simplement les services d'un
atelier de découpe emballé pesé
étiqueter les produits peuvent être
vendus immédiatement éviter les
intermédiaires permet d'obtenir un prix
plus intéressant alors que les autres
éleveurs subissent la crise le couple
lui en profite
les cours ont chuté complètement et eux
ils ont été obligés de vendre avec les
cours au ras des pâquerettes
pratiquement que nous on avait toujours
une demande et j'irai même que la
demande a été 1 amplifiée avec à cause
de la crise de la vache folle -
intermédiaire donc plus de traçabilité
mais la fraude existe certains peuvent
toujours revendre ce qui n'est pas de
leur production isabelle compte sur le
consommateur pour faire la différence
c'est vrai que n'importe qui peut se
dire producteurs éleveurs et
engraisseurs et et ne pas forcément
vendre toujours son produit c'est vrai
que bon ça devrait peut-être être un peu
plus contrôlé développé avec la crise de
la viande bovine ce type de vente est
tout à fait légal élevage
commercialisation techniques de
conditionnement la vente directe
nécessite beaucoup de travail
de multiples compétences que n'ont pas
forcément tous les éleveurs très bonne
performance pour le français jean pierre
vidal il ya quelques instants à salt
lake city et l'a gagné la première
manche du slalom messieurs devant
l'américain miller la deuxième manche
qui doit débuter dans moins d'une
demi-heure à 21h sera donc déterminante
s'il pourrait écraser loi remporter une
10e médaille pour la france où vous
voyez donc là à l'arrivée à l'issue de
cette première manche à soleil juste
mans pour clore la compétition de
patinage artistique c'était la
traditionnelle exhibition de tous les
champions un gala qui leur permettent de
montrer des figures interdite en
compétition et où chacun fait assaut
d'originalité et d'imagination
nathanaël de rincquesen et alain poirier
les scénaristes hollywoodiens n'aurait
sans doute pas fait mieux
après dix jours d'intense polémique
voilà les deux couples canadiens et
russes au centre du plus gros scandale
des je patine en main dans la main les
accusations de tricherie semble oubliée
rien de tel qu'une belle soirée de gala
pour faire la paix
dans son costume de cowboy la russe
irina slutskaya va enterrer la hache de
guerre
la vice championne olympique improvise
un petit rodéo histoire de mettre un
terme à la guerre froide russo
américaines traditionnellement le gala
c'est aussi l'occasion pour les
patineurs de présenter certains
mouvements interdits en compétition
hier soir pendant trois heures les
médaillés olympiques ont offert ce
qu'ils avaient de meilleur loin des
juges des notes et des polémiques
hu
ap
je suis encore plus plaisir maintenant
et en plus c'est notre dernier contact
avec cette patinoire olympique où on
aura pour toujours des souvenirs
fabuleux sarah yoox a une nouvelle fois
surpris le public américain vingt-quatre
heures après son titre olympique
la jeune new-yorkaise a rendu hommage
aux victimes du 11-septembre en patinant
autour d'une gerbe de fleurs déposées au
centre de la glace
laurent voulzy musiciens talentueux et
discret revient au devant de la scène
après presque dix ans de silence
son quatrième album avril sortie en
décembre dernier rencontre un grand
succès au point qu'il a été sélectionné
pour les victoires de la musique qui se
dérouleront dans quinze jours sur france
2 voici quelques images de
l'enregistrement de cet album
la maison des jeunes c'était par les
boues on n'avait pas bardot bat nathalie
où on joue et s tarn où nichent la
tonique qui nous envoie des baisers
romantique
c'était doux
les bords de marne et et je suis je
pourquoi
gentil
elle est
je connais
c'est sûr
je veux
ce sujet là
bonsoir ou laurent voulzy bonsoir cette
sélection aux victoires de la musique
c'est pas si pas une surprise puis vous
aviez déjà d'ailleurs remporté une
victoire de la musique en 92 pour votre
dernier album we ventes albums
précédents plus tôt vous aviez une
victoire spéciale pour la chanson de la
décennie belle île en mer
alors c'est pas du prix mais tu savais
tout à fait plaisir quand même c'est à
idées oui oui nous se fait plusieurs ccc
une remise de ces une distribution des
prix la meilleure récompense pour un
pour un chanteur une chanteuse ou un
interprète ou un auteur c'est de ces
publics mais en même temps quand on a la
reconnaissance des pairs c'est la cerise
sur le gâteau ça fait toujours plaisir
d'être nominé c'est vrai faut
reconnaître en scène
alors c'est votre quatrième album après
dix ans de silence gêné en ce qui vous
concerne vous pourquoi vous avez des
plages comme ça c'est une retraite
volontaire c'est non non c'est pas c'est
pas volontaire non non je fais sans
arrêt de la musique mais je mets du
beaucoup beaucoup de temps pour écrire
et beaucoup de temps surtout pour
enregistrer puis l'aï donc dans ces 10
années neuf années disons il ya eu deux
années qui ont été consacrés à la
construction d'un nouveau studio
d'enregistrement
alors si tu dois cesser c'est pourquoi
pour garder cette couleur musicale ce
taux qui vous extrêmement particulier
jambes je crois que je travaille un peu
d'une façon artisanale
et comme les artisans j'aime bien avoir
mon atelier doit les loyauté avec mes
outils et le temps et le temps que j'ai
envie de deux mecs pour pouvoir arriver
au bout en même temps c'est un luxe
incroyable je dire de se permettre de
s'absenter presse pendant dix ans et
puis de revenir de retrouver son public
et succès où il est conscient d'être
privilégiés non je suis conscient que
c'est tout simplement la reconnaissance
de votre talent des choses ousseni lundi
le nom je suis consciente pas je suis
pas conscient de tout ça je suis content
je suis non je ne me pose pas toutes ces
questions j'ai simplement envie de
mettre le temps pour arriver au bout de
mes fantasmes musicaux et
et c'est une chance la chance et c'est
de pouvoir vivre une passion que j'avais
j'ai découvert la musique quand j'avais
14 15 ans et je rêvais d'en vivre sans
savoir trop comment et c'est une chance
de pouvoir continuer d'en vivre ça c'est
une chance il faudra attendre encore
neuf ans alors un nom n'est pas planer
fille n'a dit aucun nom il suit les deux
derniers albums les trois derniers se
veut se sont succédé effectivement tous
les neuf ans neuf ans neuf ans neuf en
mai mais là c'est pas prévu peut-être
que dans l'année prochaine y en aura
donc je crois pas non non non tu vas
t'on la tournée après est né voilà voilà
l'an prochain cette année d'ailleurs
c'est au mois d'octobre le zénith et
avec une petit un petit bout de tourner
avant une grande tournée après merci
laurent voulzy des mercis à voir et la
facile victoire de la musique dans
quinze jours donc sorti sur les écrans
du film ali qui raconte la vie du boxeur
mohammed ali champion du monde à 22 ans
en 1964 sous le nom de cassius clay et
dans le rôle will smith acteur et
chanteur qui a dû suivre lui aussi un
entraînement très dur il pourrait
obtenir un oscar pour sa prestation
le film retrace les engagements sportifs
et politiques et champion pascal
deschamps et marie-jo une légende forger
un coup de poing au rythme d'un jeu de
jambes qui scotche et ses adversaires
sur l'album du ring champion du monde à
22 ans
cassius clay fut sans doute l'un des
plus grands boxeurs de tous les temps
mais sa légende il la forge a aussi à
coups de mots les mauves insolent d'un
jeune noir plein de superbe jeu tiendra
pas un quart d'heure avec toi pas dur je
m'occupais touati dessus
je suis bon je suis jeune j'ai une belle
gueule je suis un bâtard bébé une
légende fourvière d'engagement qui ont
fourni de l'est le porte drapeau des
noirs américains cas suspects le
musulman devient mohamed-ali et refuse
de partir pour la guerre du vietnam je
ne voudrais pas la bannière et cirés pas
au canada rouge la claque si vous
voulais m'arrêter fait à l'aise et ça
fait quatre siècles chercher neige pour
le respect cinq ans de plus mais ce ne
serait pas quinze mille kilomètres d'ici
collaboré à l'assassinât que tout un
peuple
si je dois mourir je mourrai ici en
battant contre vous quand je voudrais le
film raconte dix ans dans la vie d'ali
de son premier titre de champion du
monde au combat gagné contre george
foreman en 74 qu'il comparait à une
mouche mohamed ali n'avait perdu ni son
gauche ni son nous
will smith l'ex rappeur devenu star
hollywoodienne a dû s'immerger pendant
un an dans ce passé mouvementé ali lui a
rendu visite plusieurs fois sur le
tournage mais c'est de sa fille qu'est
venu le plus beau compliment
ce qu'aulas va me vois pas lui l'a vu le
film il ya quelques semaines mais ce que
sa fille m'a dit c'est qu'au bout de dix
minutes elle a complètement oublié que
c'était pas son papa à l'écran une vie
de coups de poing une vie de coups de
gueule ali le film mon justice ali un
homme aujourd'hui couverts de gloire
parce que si ça vif du sport il en a
largement transcendé les frontières
un slogan j'aime la france et des stars
pour le répéter woody allen claudia
cardinale julio iglesias roger mon entre
autres à partir de lundi ils seront sur
les chaînes de télévision étrangères
pour un message publicitaire
l'objectif faire revenir en france les
touristes moins nombreux depuis le 11
septembre sébastien legay et daniel lévy
il pleut des cordes au pays de leurs
vacances mais votre compassion et
inutiles sous le parapluie leurs
sourires ou des armes c'est normal ils
aiment la france parce que tout le monde
aime la france
si céline dion le dit c'est que c'est
forcément vrai
bon
de la france et je j'aime les femmes
j'aime la france
au cas où les touristes étrangers
auraient oublié à quel point il était
épris de notre pays une campagne de 12
millions d'euros leur rafraîchir la
mémoire
jane et john comprennent la nécessité
d'un tel message
c'est la même chose en angleterre
les américains ne viennent plus alors il
va falloir qu'on s'entraide on va chez
vous ça sonne moins bien tout ça fait
plus romantique un tel message pourrait
presque sembler patriots il n'était pas
uniquement destinée aux étrangers
le mot j'aime pas ça dont le mot france
je ne vois pas dans le mou france la
nation le pays donc ils voyagent en
avion touristique est pas la notion
politique
bref c'est tout sauf un cri de guerre
c'est juste un petit mot doux comme
l'étranger qui soudain vous offre des
fleurs et en plus en français dans le
texte
j'aime l'enfance assistée remise ce
journal dans quelques instants la météo
présentée par patrice drevet 20h50
l'émission de patrick sébastien c'est
chaud quand un mois j'aurais le plaisir
de vous retrouver demain à très bonne
soirée à tous